hi so I spend most of my time sitting in
between these two sleeveless wonders the
other day they got in a fight about
whether beer pong or flip cup was better
I don't care so I'm the moderator but
these guys are gonna have it out to
decide what's a better drinking game
beer pong or flip tub I'll let them give
you their drinking credentials ladies
first
oh thanks my name is Jorden I like to
drink I like to have fun not really sure
what other kind of credentials I need
I'm Ryan Chapman University 2013 was in
a fraternity so I definitely know a
little bit about drinking games probably
more than her but that's remains to be
seen so these guys both did a little
research and talked to a lot of people
to try and make a defense and a case for
their game of choice they're going to
show each other the footage they're
going to show me the footage and we're
going to let the viewers at home decide
who's in the right but before we do that
we have to figure out who gets to go
first and we're gonna do that through a
quick game of eye to eye let's do it all
right so a quick disclaimer from Jordan
we realized that we're breaking the
elbow rule but we don't have enough
space so get over it three two one well
that was great you're both terrible at
the three two one let's go me first all
right Ryan cue it up your desktop is a
mess dude how are you gonna have an
organized argument if you de can't even
have an organized I'll show you how I
have it organized argue secondly to load
and then I'll show you beer pong the
undeniable poster child of drinking
games and today I'm gonna prove to you
why beer pong is the greatest drinking
game in the world but if I'm right and
I'm definitely right you probably
already knew that so to start my case I
took to the streets of LA to ask what
was the best street keep in mind these
people have no idea I'm making a video
about
I in your opinion what is the best beer
drinking game the best beer should be
dream game for sure is gear ball beer
pong for social cues go
beer pong Pierpont beer pong King beer
pong beer pong dare pond this game we
call fate is that even the game let's
recap that's one two three four five six
seven eight votes for beer pong and one
to vote for King's Cup and also one vote
for some game called things yes that
means a game that I've never even heard
of got more boats than flip Cup which
put up a big fat donut you get it moving
on I could show you how fun beer pong is
by showing you clips like this epic beer
pong done from my college days should
say it has nothing to do we're talking
to the belly flop onto a table but
instead I'm just gonna show you me and
my dad chilling over a game of BP in the
backyard does anyone in your family have
sleeves on their shirts right
alright not bad for an old dude yeah
whatever
you've seen this game before and you saw
it for the first time one summer night
actually in this house when we were
having a party right what did you think
of when you first saw it I think that
night one of your uncle's was over here
it was about my age and we figured you
know what that looks like a game that we
could probably school these young kids
on I was never really into chugging
games and I figure well why not play a
skill game while having a casual sippy
or beer I mean the two just went
together natural and I believe we
actually did beat you guys all that
night and you were you lost the first
game for my recollection okay is that
what it was I don't think there's like
an age requirement or or anything like
that pretty much anybody can play oh man
see that forum dad so to close this
thing out I sent an email to the entire
office to see who would like to
participate in a beer pong tournament
within one hour I had 60 volunteers but
due to time I had to cut it down to an
18
all right let's be honest nobody wants
to watch the qualifiers so let's just
skip to the finals I will
Oh
you go girl watch Maori over elbows oh
yeah okay you gotta go
where you going every time with visa
yeah baby yeah okay well Kelsey's
carrying your team hey you gotta get
this one man okay that's love oh yeah
baby
amended what am i doing yeah really get
that Cup yeah we do that's it no please
stop hello didi hey hold on I have a
speech to make this has been a good game
oh I really enjoy I really enjoyed this
movie okay winning an Oscar
Oh Avery but alright no rebuttal was the
same front cup [ __ ] horseshit so what
do we learn here today beer pong is the
crowd favorite
it could be chill or it could be crazy
it could be enjoyed by people young and
old and it also lends its up to the
quorum and competition ie the tournament
that we just had and I guess that's my
favorite part about the competitive
aspect that it brings out of people
because when you step up to the table he
would swear that you could beat the
people across me no matter who they are
and no matter how skilled you are
I didn't make that did I it's fine
so beer pong is the most popular and
that makes it the best do you know how
many people are just gonna think of the
first drinking game that comes to their
mind and say that though they're clearly
not well educated in my ranking I asked
well people not one of the six foot cup
yeah well just wait would you agree that
just sure logistics flip Cup is a
simpler game for setup flip Cup is
perhaps a little bit more logistical
sounding to set up however I still think
it's more just like savage and crazy if
you went to a family reunion and said
hey let's play this chugging game I
don't think ever will be on board and
you're talking like an ounce at a time
and if you really don't want to be in
the game you can be out the first round
and have only drank one out that sounds
like a good game when I don't want to
play anymore I just leave which game do
you think takes more skill not if your
mom of course beer pong but that's why
it's not the best drinking game because
it takes skill to have fun you're saying
that the flip cups a better game because
anybody can play but that's not true I
think it is true I think that somebody
could step in and play beer pong and
have a better time if they weren't like
into just craziness you know what let's
go to my argument and I I'll stop using
my words and just show you what I mean
are we ready for this yeah drinking
games we've all probably played our fair
share and beer pong is arguably the most
popular right but is it the best I sure
don't think so in fact I think your pong
is stupid that's a good point you've got
some friends over and you decide to play
some drinking games you could play beer
pong
only half them will get to play at a
time and it takes what seems like
forever to finish one low energy boring
games a lot of adjectives here not a lot
of facts or you could play flip cup
everyone gets to be involved the energy
is amped up and you're having a boy
which one sounds more appealing think
I'm wrong let's see what the people of
La have to say beer pong or flip cup
which is better flip cup
I love let's go better yeah would you
pick beer pong over flip cup no ok clip
that I'm gonna say beer pong flip cup I
would say I like flip Cup
I'm better at beer pong so I'll say beer
pong in theory um I would say you know
beer pong in practice flip Cup
why it's more intense there's more more
people you're much more involved and I
think that you can really yell a lot
more in flip Cup do you think that's
more exciting than just shooting a ping
pong ball it is it's a rush yeah it's
all that pressure going into it that's
why we have to say that I think well I
think there's I don't know there's more
competitiveness like with beer pong so
the people of La chose flip Cup but do
you still think your pong is the best
drinking game well we took two people
from Ryan's tournament and decided to
see what they had to say about the
debate so you guys have taken part in
both a beer pong game in a flip Cup game
yes
which do you think is better oh man um
down up there flip Cup the game is over
pretty fast I can get games in and then
a lot of people can play there's like no
limit to how many people who can play in
a game so that's really fun and it's
teamwork gets everyone involved that's
what's fun about flip Cup if you have a
large group of people flip Cup is more
fun it's really fun oh oh so what did we
learn well the people who like beer pong
the best are mostly just the ones who
are good at it which doesn't make it the
best drinking game it just makes it the
best drinking game for sore losers with
good hand-eye coordination Mike drop the
old point she made was that more people
go play with foot pub which is like not
even necessarily really see all the
people on the street it was six to three
the more people you get involved the
more fun it is it's a more high-energy
game
just sitting there throwing a ping-pong
ball at a bunch of red Cubs what parties
all been to will be long is not high
energy I'm not even trying to say that
flip Cup is the best drinking game cuz I
don't necessarily believe that either I
just think it's better than beer pong
don't agree all you had to say is beer
pong is popular and people can be good
at I just say beer pong with a few ice
if your problem is the best and what
they ask people if they pick lip cup
over beer pong yet you had to Commission
the name would come to them but that
doesn't matter everybody pigfoot cup
point a lot of muscles over here with
these stretches I don't really know
what's going on virgin anything let me
ask you this what's the point of
drinking games one to socialize or two
to get drunk
great so flip cup does both of those
things does it beer pong goes with one
of those your pong does both those I
have never gotten drunk during a game of
beer pong it's too slow
who are you guys playing against you're
playing a 35-minute beer pong game maybe
you just just not be playing drinking
games in general I maybe you should
alright alright alright let's wrap this
up let's wrap this up so I think you
both have presented some pretty valid
arguments here on jordin side she's
saying the flip Cup is a more inclusive
game that doesn't require as much skill
has more people gets you more drunk and
a little more rowdy Ryan also presents a
valuable argument which is that there's
sort of a team aspects of beer pong
people can get dolled up make their
uniforms there's a lot of flexibility in
beer pong as to whether it's a rowdy
fratty game or whether it's just like a
casual backyard hangout kind of vibe I
feel like we both have some pretty valid
arguments I don't know if I am qualified
to really make this decision so I think
we need to throw this to the viewers at
home I'll let you guys make the right
choice
you